let's do a couple of examples dealing
with angles between parallel lines and
transversals so let's say that these two
lines are parallel so I can label as
being parallel that tells us that they
will never intersect and they're sitting
in the same plane and let's say I have a
transversal right here which is just a
line that will intersect both of those
parallel lines and I were to tell you I
were to tell you that this angle this
angle right there is 60 degrees and then
I were to ask you what is what is this
angle right over there you might want me
to see well that's very difficult that's
on a different line but you just have to
remember and the one thing I always
remember is that corresponding angles
are always equivalent and so if you look
at this angle up here on this top line
where the transversal intersects the top
line what is the corresponding angle to
where the transversal intersects this
bottom line well this is kind of the
bottom right angle you can see that
there's one two three four angles so
this is on the bottom and kind of to the
right a little bit or maybe you could
kind of view it as the southeast angle
if we're thinking in directions that way
and so the corresponding angle is right
over here
so the corresponding angle is right over
there and they're going to be equivalent
so this right here is sixty degrees now
if this angle is 60 degrees what is the
question mark angle
well the question mark angle let's call
it X right the question mark angle plus
the 60 degree angle they go halfway
around a circle they are supplementary
they will add up to 180 degrees so we
could write X plus 60 degrees is equal
to is equal to 180 degrees and if you
subtract 60 from both sides of this
equation you get X is equal to X is
equal to 120 degrees so X is equal to
120 degrees and you could keep going you
could actually figure out every every
angle form between the transversals and
the parallel lines
this is 120 degrees then the angle
opposite to it is also 120 degrees if
this angle is 60 degrees then this one
right here is also 60 degrees if this is
60 then its opposite angle is 60 degrees
and then you could either say that hey
this has to be supplementary to either
this 60 degree or this 60 degree or you
could say that this angle corresponds to
this 120 degrees so it is also 120 and
make the same exact argument this angle
is the same as this angle so it is also
under 20 degrees let's do another one
let's say I have two lines let's say I
have two lines here so it's one line let
me do that in purple and let me do the
other line in a different shade of
purple let me darken that other one a
little bit more so you have that purple
line and the other one that's another
that's a blue or something like that and
then I have a line that intersects both
of them we draw that a little bit
straighter you see if I can draw that a
little bit straighter so let me do it in
a little let me draw it like that and
let's say that this angle this angle
right here is 50 degrees and let's say
that I were also to tell you that this
angle right here is 120 degrees now the
question I want to ask here is are these
two lines parallel is this magenta line
and this blue line parallel so the way
to think about it is what would have
happened if they were parallel if they
were parallel then this and this work or
it would be corresponding angles and so
then this would be so then this would be
fifty degrees this would have to be
fifty degrees we don't know so maybe I
should put a little asterisks there to
say we're not sure whether that's fifty
degrees maybe put a question mark this
would be 50 degrees if they were
parallel but this and this would have to
be sub complementary actually regardless
of what are a supplementary they would
have to add up to 180 degrees
actually regardless of whether the lines
are parallel if I just take any line and
I have something intersecting this angle
if this angle is 50 and whatever
this angle would be they would have to
add up to 180 degrees but we see right
here that this will not add up to 180
degrees 50 plus 120 adds up to 170 so
these lines aren't parallel another way
you could have thought about it I guess
this would have maybe been a more exact
way to think about it is look if this is
120 degrees this angle right here has to
be supplementary to that it has to add
up to 180 so this angle do it in this
screen this angle right here has to be
60 degrees now this angle corresponds to
that angle but they're not equal the
corresponding angles are not equal so
these lines are not these lines are not
are not parallel